good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show wherever you're
watching us around the world Ukraine
just days away from the first
anniversary of the day Russia launched
its War we'll speak to the defense
secretary Ben Wallace shortly to find
out what further help we'll be sending
Ukraine's way and how that will affect
our forces back home as the NATO Chief
says Ukraine is using ammunition faster
than its allies can provide it plus
we're about to find out if the
government is on course to bring down
inflation that figure very shortly it's
Wednesday the 15th of February
I'm live here in Brussels where
Britain's defense secretary will join
other NATO defense ministers for talks
on how to support Ukraine and stand firm
in the face of a new Russian offensive
off the back of the Chinese spying
Scandal now warning for UK police forces
that the UK is riddled with drone
surveillance equipment all owned by
China
happiness and heartbreak could toddler
with a fatal genetic disease has been
successfully treated with the world's
most expensive drug but it's too late to
say her three-year-old sister
the parents forced to choose between
their children or their career the Sky
News reveals Nursery fees could Rise by
a thousand pounds this year
after just paying child care fees I
would have been trained after been
working for 20 pounds a month
pleased to hold a news conference at the
search for missing mum of two Nicola
bully continues with their life
never going back labor leader sakir
starmer will try to end the arguments
over anti-Semitism which have split the
party will bring that to you live at
nine o'clock
we're live in Adana in southern turkey
with the latest on what's Happening Here
just over a week on from the devastating
earthquake
[Music]
and could brexit really be hurting
conservation efforts to keep us safe
breeding programs for some of the rarest
species are being stopped because of red
tape
foreign
all of that to come busy program for you
here on the breakfast show this morning
we start though with that breaking news
on the state of the economy um let's get
more should we our business
correspondent uh Gopi is with me now um
better than expected yeah better than
expected a glimmer of good news actually
because although inflation is still
Rising far too quickly above the bank of
England's two percent Target it has come
down from that peak of 11.1 percent that
you might have remembered last year the
figure 10.1 percent was lower than
expected most economists had penciled in
a figure of 10.3 but crucially it's in
line with the bank of England's own
forecasts that it's set out a few months
ago which means that inflation is
falling just how policymakers would like
it to be this is just dropped so we
don't know what the causes of inflation
or falling inflation are yet but I'll
find out what they are and come back to
you on that
um but all of this suggests that
interest rates should hopefully start
coming down soon members of the rate
setting committee that's the bank of
England's rate setting committee having
recent weeks been making noises that
interest rates could start coming down
and this is all positive signs in that
direction they don't want to be going
too quickly but all of it suggests that
after the peak into the summer interest
rates might start falling back okay I
know that you're going to update us on
those speakers aren't you thanks very
much indeed the event secretary Ben
Wallace is with us from Brussels Mr
Wallace good morning thought on the
inflation figure first of all please
good morning
uh well good morning Kay and uh welcome
back from uh your trip look I I think uh
look it's the right it's the right
direction it's positive uh I think it
shows that the government's efforts
alongside others to try and make sure
that we deal with inflation because
inflation is really the number one enemy
to the economy is in the right direction
but you know uh we've got a long way to
go uh we'll have to keep working on it
uh and uh you know I think as as your
commentator said you know the bank of
England's Target is two percent and
we're at 10 and no one likes to be
living in a in a in a place of higher
inflation but I I really welcome the
direction of travel and we must keep
working at it
okay let's talk about money should we uh
an uphill battle with the treasury
um how much money do you need just to
stand still okay I've been in this uh
game long enough I think uh been a
minister for I don't know how many years
but it's always uphill battle with the
treasury no matter what department
you're in it's it's the right thing that
a secretary of state will argue for an
increase to meet their priorities uh and
of course between now and the budget
I've got lots of time and lots of
meetings with the chancellor to make
sure that we uh uh try and come to a
deal on it and I think uh you know I
haven't hidden the fact that we suffer
from inflation pressures as does
departments with big Capital spending
that's that's spending on hardware and
infrastructure because of course that's
where inflation goes to but um you know
we'll see I mean I'm not going to
conduct the negotiations in public but
uh obviously we're going to try and make
our way through this so that between now
and the next spending review which is in
two years time uh we can insulate
defense from many of those pressures so
you're looking according to the times
between eight and eleven billion
and I've seen lots of reports of how
much I'm looking for uh I as I said okay
I'm not going to conduct negotiations of
Treasury in public I think we've got
plenty of time I'm very much conscious
of of the overall government ambition
which is to drive down inflation as I've
just said earlier in the program that is
key that of course means it's going to
pinch all of us in all our departments
because you know ultimately the answer
cannot therefore be to flood everything
with extra spending or more borrowing
but I also know that we have a growing
threat on the world at stage and that's
why uh you know I'll obviously negotiate
with the treasury about where we can get
to to cover the next two years before we
get to the next comprehensive spending
review so is are you going to roll over
that or is it an issue of resignation if
you don't get what you want
no no let's just go to the budget okay I
think first and foremost most important
thing is uh that I present a good case
uh to the chancellor good case the Prime
Minister and of course the Prime
Minister Chancellor together will
discuss how we can get uh overall within
the spending envelope that's the
spending review we just indicate to the
markets that we're not going to sort of
just break our own fiscal disciplines
and then we'll see uh you know what I
get at the end but this is not about uh
resigning or anything else it's about
delivering defense to meet the threat
that's my duty to to the public no
matter what political party I am or
anyone else my successes will be the
same is to to be able to fund defense to
protect us from you know the likes of
Russia and other countries around the
world so suggestions um in the papers
that you'd reside if you didn't get
where you wanted a Tosh
I don't know where that comes from
but you know okay at this moment I have
to tell you there's an awful lot of
speculation in the newspapers most of it
seems to be untrue
okay uh when are we sending fighter jets
to Ukraine
oh well at the moment I've been quite
clear with that is first and foremost
what we're focusing on is delivering for
Ukraine the effects that they need which
is either the ability to strike in the
Deep that's a longer range and that's
why things like the m270 or the high
Mars are in and indeed the use of uavs
that can drop ammunitions is another way
of delivering that effect the other one
is the effect of anti-air that is
required which a fighter can deliver but
also surface-to-air missiles which is
why the International Community is
donated now thousands of anti-air
missiles I think the first point is the
effect in the long term what we've got
to do is help Ukraine's resilience uh
potentially post conflict to make sure
that they can defend themselves and
their skies and that's why training
people to fly fighter jets is an
important step in that direction but you
know this this the key here is that
these are fighter jets these are not
handheld anti-tank weapons these are
these are aircraft that take not only
months to train on but also aircraft
that require effectively a very
substantial pit crew to support it if
you think about you know it's very diff
different gifting a sort of normal car
that you and I might drive around with
and a Formula One car you gift a Formula
One car it comes with a pit crew it
needs the crew to start it he needs the
crew to service it is a long tail that
goes with a fighter aircraft and I think
you know we can help Ukraine sooner by
delivering the effects they need on the
battlefield rather than the
platform-specific uh request
Can't Give Them Enough ammunition though
can we
I think we're giving them lots of
ammunition and we continue to do so uh
if you look at the amount of the
International Community have donated
we're talking tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands of rounds of ammunition
ammunitions we've just we continue to
put in 2.3 billion pounds worth of
support within this financial year and
another 2.3 billion next year and we are
actually putting in a huge amount okay
the questions that we will be making
sure we help with is getting it
delivered getting it across the border
remember we can't fly in this equipment
because of Russia's efforts to shoot
down anything that was would be flying
and we bring them in obviously across
border and we make sure we get it to
them in the front line and you know the
ukrainians are doing a fantastic job uh
and in under very difficult
circumstances the uh later sort of
Russian effort uh around a town a mining
town
um produced uh sadly but but
nevertheless necessarily the Ukrainian
fight uh made sure that literally a
brigade of Russians was wiped out over
the last week that's nearly over a
thousand men killed because of poor
Russian equipment and poor Russian
strategy
I know hacking our CCTV cameras
uh well they're not hopefully I don't
think they are hacking our sensitive
CCTV cameras uh and uh you know we take
every effort to protect areas that are
sensitive uh from anybody hacking it
whether it's China or uh whether it is
another nation and there are two parts
okay to protecting our infrastructure
one is to make sure that the quality of
the equipment we buy is protected from
being hacked uh and that doesn't really
matter who makes it it's making sure
that if we buy sort of cheap knockoffs
you're going to be in a position where
you're going to be more vulnerable in
whether you're buying for your home
equipment or whether you're buying uh
for a government organization or a local
Council or a business you should always
make sure you're buying good quality as
a way to protect yourself and then the
second one is as you point out whether
or not we think they're particularly
vulnerabilities in in product sourced
from certain countries such as China and
you'll remember the Huawei debate where
the government took a decision that it
would rid its sensitive networks of
anything to do with Huawei and that's
the direction of travel we're going in
are we doing enough to help the people
in the earthquake zone in Southeastern
turkey and Northwestern Syria the
British public raised 65 million pounds
in four days doing the the maths it
looks as though the government has given
maybe about 11 million pounds worth of
Aid so far as them all coming
well first of all okay there's there's
Aid in cash and there's Aid in kind
um you know I've deployed a role to
hospital which I think is going to be
set up from today I've deployed a C-130
Hercules with a critical care crew that
can move casualties around Turkey we've
provided lots of Transport a400 Aircraft
to move in both humanitarian Aid and
other Aid and I'm here in NATO today
where the Secretary General has asked me
if there's any more
um airlift I can provide to help NATO
supplies go in of humanitarian Aid and
we're going to do that so in kind I
think we've provided and we'll continue
to provide an awful lot in value
um I almost daily speak to my or or I'm
in text engagement or indeed communicate
with my Turkish can Department Minister
akar uh only the day before yesterday I
offered him uh troops if he needed it uh
to help in that humanitarian effort and
for now we are in the hands of the
Turkish Authority and the United Nations
in Syria if they request more we are
very very open to looking at that okay
let's just finish briefly where we
started the treasury thinks the mod
wastes money do you
uh well I think the treasury will make
that point as I asked for more money uh
look historically the trade the Mad has
bought into equipment uh that I think
hasn't necessarily delivered but
remember 85 of our procurements are on
budget on time some of the major
projects they span 20 years and in that
time threat changes technology changes
and inflation changes and of course that
often leads to you know very difficult
conversations about either how many
units we can buy in the end or indeed
cost control but it can be better you'll
be glad to know that since I became
defense secretary and we've delivered a
balanced budget for two years and and
heading towards three that's the first I
think almost since the war that we've
managed to get those results
consistently but you know I'm fixing
projects that were commissioned as far
back as the labor government you know
the Ajax uh vehicle which is often
quoted was commissioned in March 2010 uh
and has been a troubled program and uh
we're now in a place where I think it's
back on track our it's passed its first
level of Trials and we're interested
next set so you know I think uh you
can't you can't hold the sins of my
forefathers against me I'm determined to
make sure we we change those practices
but that doesn't also change the fact
that threat is growing and what we've
seen since 1991 since the end of the
Cold War is a consistent effectively
raiding of the defense budget uh uh over
time and maybe a peace dividend was uh
appropriate uh straight after the Cold
War we had huge armies in Europe the
Cold War finished and it was right that
the taxpayer who had invested in defense
got a return on that the problem is that
continued and has continued to farm too
many decades as the threat has increased
and I've been very open here that the
threat has increased and just like other
parts of government when demand threat
increases we should reconsider how much
we fund it which is why Boris Johnson
and Rishi sunak when he was Chancellor
gave us 16 billion pounds extra uh back
in 2020 it was the first real turning of
the corner with real money rather than
sort of fantasy efficiency saving the
things that were supposedly the way they
used to fund that that sort of increase
and that has allowed us to start
modernizing our Armed Forces which has
been desperately needed but genuinely
start to modernize our Armed Forces okay
um hopefully Jeremy Hunt was listening
to you good to talk to you as always
safe journey back home thank you thank
you Adam Parsons standing by for us in
Brussels this morning Adam your thoughts
good morning to you
yeah there's there's a lot in there
Trump pick I mean Ben Wallace is right
of course is that the United Kingdom is
not the only member of NATO that has
gone through a bit of soul-searching
recently about whether they cut back too
far on uh on defense spending that
whether they reduce their capability and
are now having to to step it up again I
think as ever the United States when it
arrives at NATO you can almost feel that
kind of
side that comes out when the U.S frankly
thinks that it is carrying a
disproportionate burden that is
something that former president Donald
Trump came out very clearly and said but
if you ever talk to American diplomats
they do look at the figures and notice
just how much they are spending and
they'll say it again here is that the US
does feel that it is largely Bank
rolling the resistance to Ukraine
frankly you go across NATO you have
discovered that the Germans the French
the European Union and of course the
British and the Americans all think that
they're leading the resistance to
Ukraine interesting to see what Mr
Wallace talked about in terms of those
specifics and I think he is echoing what
we've heard from a number of people both
on and off the Record in terms of this
discussion about fighter jets clearly
Vladimir zielinski came and did a big
pitch for fighter jets in the UK and
across Europe but the the resistance to
that diplomatically has always been that
f22s are incredibly complicated they
take so much effort that I think NATO
has coalesced around this idea that what
it really needs to do is provide the
things Ukraine needs for a nutritional
ground war and that is about Munitions
and ammunitions and the shells that
Ukraine is using up at a huge rate okay
for now
well this morning in central London
Ashner CCTV are the Chinese spying on us
um
don't think so he said
no Ben Wallace was quite quick there to
defend the fact that many of the CCTV
cameras used across the UK and his words
were of quality and haven't been bought
cheaply the Watchdog in this scenario
does disagree with a lot of that he says
43 police forces across England and
Wales the National Crime agency and in
government buildings like the one behind
me in the ministry of Defense they are
in fact these chinese-made CCTV cameras
but also surveillance equipment in use
and drones as well the UK has fast
become one of the most watched countries
in the world most surveyed countries in
the world and what this raises questions
about is not only surveillance and
privacy and not only about who is
watching us but how that information is
being analyzed too who is accessing that
information and in what way is that
quite sensitive data and potentially
footage is being accessed and being used
and in what what way what we have found
in this report Fraser Sampson says that
the UK is riddled with these security
cameras because often we find that many
of these Chinese security cameras are
using quite Advanced Analytical software
includes things like facial recognition
vehicle identification and object
tracking things that aren't just
necessarily watching over people's every
move in a retrospective way but is live
recording people's movements even as we
stand here behind me the ministry of
Justice I've counted about six cameras
that are watching us and of course
that's a government building but it's
who else is watching us that's the big
question I do so but I thank you well
the White House says three unidentified
objects shot down from the skies last
week were likely to be benign three
objects shot down over both the US and
Canada were said to be much smaller than
the suspected Chinese spy balloon
officials have drawn a clear distinction
between the three objects and the
balloon which flew into U.S airspace
near a military base which they suspect
was involved in surveillance still to
come on the program for you we'll chat
more about the UFOs that have been
making headlines this past week just
buying or simply flying
is labor at peace over anti-Semitism
labor MP day Margaret Hodge might not
agree we'll hear from her shortly
and the race to re-arm Ukraine I'm going
to be speaking to the former director of
the British Army staff just after eight
o'clock
[Music]
19 month old baby with a fatal genetic
disease has the chance of a normal life
thanks to the world's most expensive
gene therapy drug Teddy Shaw and her
elder sister Nala were both diagnosed
with a rare condition that damages the
organs and nervous system the family
have said all there there although there
is hope amongst the pain for Teddy
thanks to the drug listed at almost 3
million pounds three-year-old Nala is
too far advanced in her illness to
benefit from the treatment
meantime parents particularly moms are
being forced to choose between their
career
and their children because of the cost
of child care new figures obtained by
Sky News show that nurseries are
expected to raise their fees by an
average of a thousand pounds this year
yet they're already amongst the most
expensive in the whole world tomorrow
has been looking into this for us
actually hi tomorrow at hospital morning
Kate well the soaring cost of child care
we're looking at for a toddler attending
full-time about 14 000 pounds a year in
the UK is set to go up again this year
and even families with two incomes who
think they're doing okay are having to
have one parent give up work usually the
mum in order to pay for child care I
spoke to a family in this situation and
looked at how widespread it is this is
my report
it's 7 30 and three-year-old Harriet is
nearly ready for preschool
her parents have always worked but for
baby brother Bobby the cost of child
care is now beyond their reach once we
worked it out after just paying child
care fees I would have been trying I
would have been working for 20 pounds a
month
mum Becky feels she's been forced to
give up her job in sales she'll stay at
home and the family will rely on the
wages of her partner Steve an
electrician
must have been a daunting decision for
you giving up your career I always
wanted to be a working Bob
um
you know never envisaged myself being a
stay-at-home parent and you know just
cooking cleaning bringing children up
I'm not asking other people to pay for
my children and and I definitely don't
want people's taxes to go up because of
it and you know I think we need to look
at where the assigned taxes to pay for
what services and and even just slightly
subsidize the cost of fees so it's
affordable
caring for and educating the very
youngest children is a costly business
but those costs are rising at an
eye-watering rate
a survey for Sky News by the early years
Alliance found child care providers will
raise fees by an average of eight
percent this year around a thousand
pounds for a child under three attending
full-time
already two-thirds of parents say they
spend more on child care than on their
rent or mortgage
parents of three and four-year-olds get
15 free hours a week or 30 if both
parents are working
so their costs are usually lower
but that leaves a gap for children under
three we end up in a situation where the
youngest children have the highest
prices they're ever going to pay with
the least access to government support
and it's coming at this critical moment
where parents are making the decision
about whether or not to go back to work
after they've been on Parental leave
both political parties are working on a
new child care offer for parents ahead
of the next election the challenge is to
make a real impact on family finances
which doesn't cut corners for children
so mom's having to give up work because
they'd literally just can't afford to
send their children to Nursery people in
good jobs who thought they were going to
be okay perhaps were able to pay for
like their first child to be in
childcare are now finding it so
expensive that it's simply not worth
them working they would be losing money
now conservative MPS are really
ratcheting up the pressure on the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt saying he should
take action in the March budget to help
parents particularly of one and
two-year-olds because that's when the
mums are having to make these decisions
to give up work to put more money into
it now an idea that he was was drawn up
for him to extend free child care hours
to two-year-olds I understand it's not
happening because it's been ruled as too
expensive now the Department of
Education tell me that they are looking
at options to improve the cost
flexibility and availability of child
care and have spent a record amount to
spend 20 billion over the last five
years but clearly it's not working for a
lot of parents and I think there's going
to be growing pressure for the
chancellor to change the system okay and
budget next month of course tomorrow for
now thank you
um in other news researchers in the
United States have said a game-changing
male contraceptive pill that reduces
fertility quickly and temporarily could
be possible a study by Val Cornell
medicine found the pill was 100
effective in the first two hours
reducing to 91 within three hours and
showed no negative Health impacts when
taken for six weeks
virgin orbit says the reason its rocket
broke up on its first flight out of the
UK was because a fuel filter was
dislodged the launcher one rocket broke
up as it was due to take nine satellites
into orbit after taking off from
Spaceport Cornwall the payloads crashed
into the Atlantic
new sentencing guidelines have been
published to clamp down on retailers who
sell knives to Children the legislation
which comes into force in England and
Wales on the 1st of April could mean
huge fines for large organizations and
individual shopkeepers who sell knives
to under 18 year olds without proper
safeguards
police are expected to
interference later on today as a search
for missing mother of two Nicola bully
continues Miss bully disappeared while
walking her dog in the village of Saint
Michael's on Y in Lancashire on the 27th
of January Lancashire police say they
believe the 45 year old fell into the
river wire Charlotte Drake who's lived
next door to Nicola and her family for
five years spoke of the hell she's faced
since her friend went missing
she's one of us that's I think why it's
hit so many of us so hard around here
the women that the mums because we've
all done this walk it could it feels
like it could have been any one of us
and as a person she's so caring and so
considerate
we have to give that back to her and
that level of effort that she I know she
would be giving to us
let's find out what's that we I should
say we will be there at the scene with
Lindsay in the next hour quick look at
the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
next few days will be more unsettled
than recently but the southeast will
stay largely fine and dry today
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now then what to wear for a coronation
here is a clue in the past every new
Queen consort would have a dual
encrusted crime specially made for a
coronation however this year in the
interests of sustainability Camilla has
opted to wear the crown of one of her
forebearers Queen Mary's 1911 Crown
albeit with a brilliant upgrade it will
be reset with diamonds from Queen
Elizabeth II's personal jury collection
in tribute to the late Queen that's
rather beautiful isn't it
um now how about this for your Wednesday
morning earworm and something to lift
your spirits
is brexit really hurting conservation
efforts zoo keepers are saying breeding
programs for some of the rare species
rarest species are being stopped because
of red tape 945 speaking to the British
and Irish Association of zoos and
Aquariums stay tuned to find out if
brexit is stopping us from helping
little ones like him
also still to come on the program before
you taken hostage at gunpoint but who is
he who's holding him and what will it
take to get him free more after the
break
[Music]
and more on anti-Semitism with labor
hello again everybody let me tell you
about the defense secretary Ben Wallace
he was on the program a short time ago
he says he's in an uphill battle with
the treasury over his defense budget
he's under pressure to boost spending on
the armed forces and is also being
pressed to send more weapons and
ammunition to Ukraine but he says his
conversations with the treasury are not
bringing him to the brink of resignation
Are You Gonna Roll Over that or is it an
issue of resignation if you don't get
what you want
no let's just go to the budget okay I
think first and foremost most important
thing is that I present a good case uh
to the chancellor good case the Prime
Minister and of course the Prime
Minister and Chancellor together will
discuss how we can get uh overall within
the spending envelope that's the
spending reviewiness indicate to the
markets that we're not going to sort of
just break our own fiscal disciplines so
suggestions
um in the papers that you'd reside if
you didn't get where you wanted a Tosh
I don't know where that comes from
um but you know okay at this moment uh I
have to tell you there's an awful lot of
speculation in the newspapers most of it
seems to be untrue
[Music]
but um he would continue to speak to his
opposite number in turkey and if trips
were needed to help with that recovery
operation then they would certainly be
sent to help uh you end saying its first
Convoy carrying Aid to the victims of
last week's earthquakes has entered the
rebel-held region of Northwest Syria
after passing through a newly opened
border crossing let's have a lot number
of people killed in the earthquake in
turkey and Syria has now reached 41
000 people 41 000 as part of an
agreement with the United Nations
president Assad has opened up two
further border crossings to get Aid into
rebbled hell parts of the country there
you go
until now there's only been one open
border crossing from Turkey into Syria
and that's the bab alhawa uh the new
Crossing at bab al-salam and Al Rai for
an initial period of three months these
will allow Aid into opposition held
parts of Northern Syria such as idlib
which was so badly impacted by the
earthquake meanwhile in Southeastern
turkey anger is growing at the
government's apparent failure to ensure
building standards were maintained
making the earthquakes destruction even
worse
Cordelia visited antakia and Adana and
sent this report
every time they hear the helicopter here
there's a sudden burst of Hope and a
rush of adrenaline
the staff at Adana City Hospital are
still receiving survivors
this time it's a 26 year old teacher
this is astonishing to see more than a
week after the earthquake hit this woman
has managed to fall through what
strength that must have taken and what
horror she must have endured
this is the moment M A atcool was
discovered
it's more than 200 hours since her
six-story building has collapsed
exhausted on the edge of life and death
in the eight days she's been trapped she
might be suffering tissue damage due to
hunger and thirst our patients will most
likely suffer from renal failure and
that's why we'll have to monitor her in
our Intensive Care Unit
it's hard to Fathom how anyone made it
through these doors especially
eight-month-old beer Jay she fell from
the fifth floor her leg is broken but
doctors are hopeful she'll make a full
recovery
her mother kneelai thought she'd lost
all three of her children
at first when I called out to my kids I
didn't hear any response I didn't want
to get out alive then I thought how will
I survive this if my family are no more
amazingly BJ and her eldest sister did
make it but in the rubble Neil I found
the body of her other child
all of my daughters are Miracles but I
am without one I have lost her now I'm
seeking refuge in my daughter birje
being alive I find solace in her
thank you
in Antarctica the burden of the search
is heavy
mounds of Despair everywhere
but no one is ready to let go the night
before a couple was rescued and now the
race is on to find their 26 year old son
you don't hear sounds anymore after
three four days you cannot see it sounds
but you say
if you hear my voice can you please hit
against the wall with something
any kind of nuts and we have some
gadgets on our gadgets we can hear
clearly
even if it's scratching the wall with
the nails
but after an agonizing weight
the worst news the family forced to
identify his body
is as cruel as it is coarse
yet still they search looking for any
little clue that may help them Salvage
life or at very least honor the Dead
Cordelia is with us now
um High Cordelia it really is very much
a recovery operation Now isn't it um is
support still coming through
yes I mean it's a mixed picture Okay
depending on where you are uh in the
south of the country you know in these
big cities we're seeing large rescue
operations a lot of heavy equipment and
Machinery but there are those isolated
Villages and communities where help
hasn't got through where there is still
a lot of people suspected that that
families are desperately hoping they can
pull from the rubble now Britain has
been offering its help the defense
secretary Ben Wallace saying he is
willing to provide more troops if and
when needed to Turkey I think what is
striking at the moment here is the
growing anger and frustration around the
safety of these buildings okay a lot of
people concerned that amnesties were
granted to buildings that the government
that others knew was simply not safe and
I think we'll see more questions levied
at them and at contractors who we know
have been arrested over the last few
days how help needed here help
desperately needed of course in Syria
where three age routes are now opened
for the next three months at least but
so much still needed there okay
but no thank you
um breaking news and two people have
been charged following the deaths of a
16 year old Brian he gay a 15 year old
girl from Warrington and a 15 year old
boy from Lee in Lancashire have been
charged with murder Ronnie's body was
discovered in linear parking culture on
Saturday afternoon
Jeremy corbyn's time as labor party
leader was fraught with claims of
anti-Semitism which split the party
today kirstama wants to show the
arguments are over China by labor MP for
The Barking day Margaret Hodge one of
those was affected by the rise high so
to see thanks for coming in really
appreciate it
um Your Leader will say later on today
in a speech that the party has changed
what proof is that
well let's just take the anti-Semitism
first that one of the first phone calls
that
testosterama made after he became
elected leader was to be and to other
Jews who had suffered under the time of
Jew hate with corbyn and he promised us
then that he would show demonstrate zero
tolerance to anti-Semitism and he's
acted so we've got a completely new
complaints mechanism with much speedier
it's much more comfortable and
transparency transparent people have
been expelled from the labor party in
their hundreds and we've had intensive
training of labor party members and
decision makers to ensure that they are
totally aware of what constitutes
anti-Semitism that's one bit but the
party's changed much more fundamentally
if you think about things like our
attitude and the economy to businesses
the way that we approach business that's
a complete transformation from the days
of corbyn or if you think about us on
the global stage that you're looking at
now we are now firmly working with NATO
and with the West to ensure that
stability for our values in the globe in
the global world all that is a massive
transformational change it's not
superficial yeah
yeah if he was so appalled by the way
the party was behaving under Jeremy
corbyn why didn't he stop it at the time
he was part of the cabinet
I think that time was horribly difficult
putting myself back into it people had
to take
personal decisions as hard as to how
they were going to respond to the
appalling circumstances in which we
found ourselves wrong isn't it and you
know it it you have to stand up and be
counted as a politician and he was part
of that cabinet and he let it go on well
let me just say this that some members
felt so terrible about it they left I
was among those that those people that
decided to find it from within and uh
care decided to fight it privately and I
think those were really really really
difficult decisions to take at the time
but what I can say to you is Care's
leadership since he became elected as
either a labor party you just can't
quarrel with it if you'd said to me okay
two years ago when we had that terrible
report horrific day with the ehrc saying
that we were guilty of Jew hate if you'd
said to me two years on things will be
different and you'll be given a clean
bit of Health I wouldn't have believed
you so I'm proud to say that I was wrong
I lived through the age teachers when we
were fighting militant and it took much
much longer than and I think the reason
we'd be unable to manage it much more
quickly now is actually that clear
determined detailed sort of absolutely
driven leadership that we've had from
kirstana yeah since he took over
apparently it's reported there have been
700 anti-Semitism cases has the problem
really gone away no and I'll tell you
why it won't have totally gone away if
you allow something like that anti-jew
hate to move from the fringes of your
party into the mainstream it takes time
to transform the culture we've put
everything in place it's a zillion times
better we're beginning to see things
emerging you know I talk about flowers
blooming so Barnet which was an ERA with
a very strong population voted labor in
the local elections were beginning to
get stunningly strong labor people
Jewish people standing as Labor
candidates but is it all dealt with no
we've got to keep our foot on the
accelerator and transforming that
culture to show to be restored to the
party that I joined because I am a Jew
and because I fight racism to restore it
to those values its basic values will
always take time
it was a dark chapter in the party's
history will it always be marred by that
I think we'll get no I don't think it
will be I think people now are so
focused on providing an alternative uh
party and government that will provide
hope that you know will ensure that
we're not corrupt which is uh the the
things that we're facing now that really
will invest in health and education and
deal with the cost of living crisis I
think I think it will
um it will diminish but let me just say
this I don't want us to forget it
completely because I don't want it ever
to happen again here's a tricky one for
the end
um what should happen to Jeremy corbyn
oh I've absolutely no doubt about that I
think I have absolute
can't think of any circumstances in
which Jeremy corbyn could ever stand as
a labor candidate again still a member
of the party isn't he he's still a
member of the party I'm actually allowed
to be
um well I think the most important thing
is that he will not stand as a candidate
and so it's it's a matter of his own
doing he's been the master of his own
destiny he knew what he did uh he knows
what it is would he be banned from the
party well I think the party's moved on
actually ironically I think I've moved
on the parties where the country's moved
on they're not voting for us again and
if you're somebody who believe who
promotes anti-jew hate if you're
somebody who thinks that uh we shouldn't
be talking to business
if your party if you're somebody who is
anti-native I think you should be
walking away from the labor party it's
not your TV banned from the party why
why are you so hesitant because I'm not
being hesitant I just think at the
moment you know it's a matter for him
he's got hello again everybody welcome
back to the breakfast show before the
break we teased and asked if you knew
whose birthday was um today we gave you
a few clues about her being a Bond girl
and the like well
did you guess 72nd birthday for Jane
Seymour the actress who played Solitaire
in Live and Let Die the love interest of
Sir Roger Moore's James Bond she also
won two Golden Globes one for East of
Eden great great movie and another for
Dr Quinn Medicine Woman plus an Emmy for
Onassis the richest man in the world
good for her
now U.S officials say the last three of
the four objects shot down in the skies
uh over both
um America and Canada could be benign
commercial or research efforts but
there's still little information on the
original suspected surveillance balloon
let's get a quick reminder of what
happened um here we go the suspected
Chinese spy balloon became of concern
earlier this month when it was tracked
above the town of Billings in Montana
around 200 miles from a nuclear missile
field at Malmstrom Air Force Base okay
fourth of Feb on the instruction from
President Joe Biden a U.S F-22 fighter
jet shot down the suspected Chinese
spyballoon of the South Carolina coast
there we go last Friday President Biden
ordered a fighter jet to shoot down an
unidentified high altitude object off
Northern Alaska dead horse love it now
the White House said the object was the
size of a small car and posed a
reasonable threat to civilian Aviation
Alaska is home to nine military bases on
Saturday Canadian Prime Minister
confirmed that a U.S F-22 jet
accompanied by Canadian aircraft shot
down and unidentified object over the
mountainous and sparsely populated
territory of Yukon in the Canadian
Northwest a region which borders the
United States Alaska side and last
Sunday a US F-16 jet fired a missile and
downed another unidentified object over
Lake Huron on the U.S Canadian border
U.S authorities say the object flew near
sensitive military sites and could have
been used for spying so what is going on
spying flying or Sim simply keeping an
eye on the weather for more now joined
by author and astronomer David
Whitehouse hi it's always great to see
you thanks for coming in what's going on
well the first object was definitely a
spy Bloom yeah it was obvious from the
pictures of it that it was too large to
be meteorological it had large solar
panels large equipment so that was
obviously a spy Bloom and what seems to
have happened is that these are
fairly small objects really in the sky
and they moved slowly and America was
not looking for them and I think that
China took advantage of this and of the
general American Air Force dismisses
UFOs
they took advantage of this Gap in their
space surveillance of their airspace and
we're sort of floating these spy
Platforms in as you say it went over
American base and it was probably doing
something like
intercepting cell phone Communications
among military personnel and whatever it
could suck up from signal
intertelligence the other three since
then seem to be a bit of a mystery
because although as you said the
Americans say they are benign one of
them does seem to be large one of them
does seem to they said was octagonal
with sort of tethers
emerging from it and it was hard to see
how something like that has the
propulsion to stay airborne so they're
probably
a meteorological scientific platforms or
even spy platforms from another nation
that have been taking advantage of this
Gap in surveillance but of course you
know we need the debris from the ground
which is difficult why do they need to
do that I thought they had stuff in
space that they could read number plates
from they can and I'm sure that America
Woods was would be looking at its spy
satellite solidone territory to see if
he could see these things but in the
past there have been UFOs which America
has uh has either dismissed as being
unimportant ignored
um so they may have sort of Fallen under
the radio from that so to speak although
there is a a category of UFOs called Tic
Tacs these small ones that were seen by
American fighter pilots which are a
genuine mystery nobody knows what they
are but they seem to be different from
the type of things that's fallen over
Canada so
it's an emerging new subject if you like
we're seeing things we haven't seen okay
we are out of time but hopefully you'll
come back and talk about them in more
detail thank you very much indeed more
to come in just a moment stay tuned
foreign
[Music]